welcome
to simply learn webinar redefining
future readiness for the modern graduate
expert tips for a successful career
today dr sandeep chenchetti he is the
vice
chancellor srm institute of science and
technology
and he will be hosted by kash abdullah
who is the chief business officer of
simply learn before we start a few
instructions on how to
ask us questions you can use the
question button to put in a q a question
which we will log and get to at the end
of the presentation in the q a session
you can use the chat button to send
comments in
please set it to all panelists and that
way we will be able to
all see it here and if there are
questions in the chat flow we will also
log those for answers
at the end of the session with that
let's get started and i'm going to turn
it over to the law
who will introduce dr sanchetti
sorry keshev thanks thanks to it
and hi everyone and welcome
to this webinar that we have
on the future readiness of our graduates
and how do they get ready for a
successful career in the current
environment i am delighted to welcome dr
sanchez
who is as steward mentioned the vice
chancellor at srm university
um i think let me briefly introduce dr
sanchez for our viewers
so dr sandeep sanchez is currently the
vice chancellor of the
srm university chilling so in the past
he's been
president of the association of indian
universities
he's also been a director and president
of a number of prestigious schools in
the past
and so and just name few of them uh
so we have manipar manipal university
jaipur
nit delhi nit surat khal and idi trichy
niti calicut and he's also mentored a
lot of other schools
so uh you know with more than 36 years
of teaching and
experience of leading universities he's
aptly known as the institution builder
and i really can't think of a better way
of
complementing the journey that dr
sanchez had um
i think apart from this he's also a
member of lot of industry and policy
influencing bodies
including fiki ciitel innovation mission
and so on
and apart from work he's a player of
bridge and squash
and also part of rotary and few other
social organizations
so i think really honored to have dr
sanchati with us today and
look forward to a very engaging
discussion and i can't think of anybody
better than him to
uh shed light on the topic that we are
talking about today
uh so dr essentially welcome and uh
thank you thank you mr akasha thank you
so much for
introducing me and also inviting me
thank you to
simply learn as well and all others mr
stewart
and puja for facilitating
this interaction very happy to join you
thank you sir so let me get started
with you know a question which is so
keeping it slightly open-ended to start
with so that we can layer canvas for
this
discussion and you know kind of uh then
get deeper
so uh dr sanchez could you give us a
sense of like over the last
10-15 years how have you seen the
change that you know the kind of
market scenario and what our graduates
enter after finishing their program i
mean
what what is the what is the journey
that you've seen and you know how do you
see
today in comparison to that so would
love to just get
context on you know how you look at it
okay if uh thank you uh if i take last
15 years
the changes have been much more rapid
primarily because
of the emergence of or the omni presence
of what we call
computers in the internet yes they they
they appeared on in in indian scenario
maybe
in late 90s or early 2000s but the
real presence of the technology has made
the changes much
bigger i would say internet access is
still improving and that has made the
biggest change
these are the two major technological
revolutions
in the history of mankind which has
impacted us yes
there might have been steam engines
there might have been various other
things which were there bulbs and all
that
but these are the two topmost and their
real setting in our
normal life is in recent times and
therefore everything has changed
and if you see the recent last couple of
years
including the kovitz situation i think
everything else has changed
uh uh as we know that uh kovet has been
a big change maker
so today uh one can always say that
the way we eat or the way we meet or
maybe
we greet or treat or whatever that may
be everything is changing and in a very
very big fashion
and that's impacting the students the
teachers the relationship between them
education set up and of course the job
market also
so earlier possibly you can say that the
students are very happy
with getting a job getting an
engineering degree let's say if we are
talking about engineering
as a primary course here then they were
very happy but today they are more
aspirational they are trying to decide
the fate
of their life by saying what they want
and what they don't want
there was a time if i if i'm not wrong
maybe till early 2000 you can say that
top iit graduates possibly would be
aspiring to go abroad very easily for
whatever they wanted to do but today
they are
they are very happy to be remaining in
india and doing whatever they can
say with the same set of people probably
were aspirational
for what you call civil services or
foreign services or the top
top notch government services which were
there but today those government jobs
have shifted to google jobs they would
be aspiring for google
similarly i can possibly say that
instead of
becoming an innovator or inventor in a
big way
at that time doing something fundamental
they would like to go to
investment banking so shifts are far too
many in terms of what you can say
the the rationals have changed the
relations have changed
the dreams have changed the drivers have
changed
and what has not changed or what had
not changed much was the education let
me tell you i'm sorry to say that i'm
belonging to that domain but we are very
very traditional
and it's only in recent times last two
three years that we have started
changing
a big way trying to keep the pace with
water stream and so on
even till today you can say that our
teaching learning
especially in indian context is either
regulatory centric
or institutional centric and at the best
teacher center if teacher is good
something will happen it is still
nowhere near
student centricity i think that change
is
now coming uh or that eruption or change
is happening right now
and therefore i would say that it's
happening for good
but one reason why it didn't happen
earlier and why it's happening now is
once again the technology
some of these things were attempted by
us earlier we attempted 10 years back a
virtual university concept with iit
madras
when i was myself in government and we
failed because
it was rather premature or not
appropriate in terms of what was the
support available
so these are some of the changes i would
say
which i have seen in past let's say 10
to 15 years
but we if we make the time frame bigger
i think there's a complete
sea change which is there the entire set
of subjects
teaching learning the experimentation
the attributes which instrument need to
develop while graduating everything has
changed
so but change is a constant as we know
and we are all working towards
this to make sure that our students are
always benefited and they are able to
serve the
industry or society or any anything they
want to do in their life yeah they
become capable
right dr sensati some of the things that
you mentioned about this entire
change i i can't agree more i mean i i'd
simply learn i recall that
till as little as four years back a lot
of times
so we we offer online curriculum for a
lot of the programs and
uh this is through live classes and what
we kept hearing from a lot of students
was that
they would prefer to do it as an offline
classroom right and so
there was a journey of adoption that
over the last
seven eight years we have seen that
gradually people getting more and more
comfortable with
virtual learning and virtual mode of
interaction and stuff like that
and of course now it's gone to the other
extreme where
you know people have completely adopted
it because they don't have a choice
so virtual is the new real as you know
or new normal
absolutely so coming back to you know
the topic that we were discussing so
through this 10 15 years while
on one side technology has driven lot of
change in terms of
people's aspirations and habits and
choices and so on
um how do you see the industry
expectation changing that let's say
in 90s and then 2000s and now in the
closer to 2020
um so so what comes in the media and
what we
keep hearing is more specific trends
which are in the limelight that let's
say
i t job boom then you know sales and
marketing or bpo jobs and then
more recently data jobs so this is
always it's the tip of the iceberg
but there's a lot of stuff that's going
on right that when you think about
large number of graduates getting into
the industry and kind of starting their
careers and so on
um how do you see that changing demand
from the industry and
you know what kind of uh profiles are
they looking for what kind of skills are
they looking for and
how is that progress through the time
yeah i would say that
earlier the testing or the acceptability
or the process of selection
for a job or acceptability for a job was
more
what a person can reproduce as a
knowledge or the content
or the direct deliverables but today
they are not
looking necessarily looking at that
reason for that is
the life of any domain or any specific
product or process
is getting shorter and by that
nature of jobs are also changing because
they know that if they have to take one
a person and nurture him and then carry
him
or her for a longer time one should be
adoptable so set of skills are
completely changing
today i find very easily that the top of
her class may not find
uh easy to get a job in any top
industry unless he or she depicts or
has extra outside skills or traits or
maybe
attributes which will suit so one of the
biggest thing in my opinion
which is uh changing is people try to
see
whether this person who is going to get
a job or going to be offered a job
is adaptable or not can he or she
uh change according to the circumstances
can he or she be having an ability
what we call learning to learn this was
not the case five ten years back
and probably students themselves who are
expecting
that once they study well and they
master a domain so-called master
domain by those standards will probably
survive for 30 40 years in their
life they don't have to do much and now
it is a
well said thing that after a few years
of job or whatever
activities one may have to recharge the
batteries
and that may be either skilling doing
courses from simply learn or going for a
master's program
or maybe self-learn whatever it may be
so domains are changing very fast the
only challenge for
students and for us who are supposedly
the trainers for the students
uh though it's an age of self-learning
so we say that
we are only facilitators we are only
mentors in some way we cannot do
everything
but the only challenge is we do not know
what to expect in future
future is becoming difficult to predict
though in india we have never tried to
foresee
what we need through our concerted
effort by any agency that what kind of
let's say engineers of graduates will
want a specialization wise or otherwise
or number wise
so there has been a challenge so what
happens here
is by the the masses reaction or the
crowd
reaction but fortunately i t is one
biggest driver for the country
and it9scom has been able to
to spell out certain things which are
required
and accordingly uh things have changed
in the academic domain
and today they've gone a step ahead
whether it is
ecs or whether it is wipro or whether it
is
any other infosys or whatever big giants
of
the country they have started
collaborating with the indian higher
education system
in a slightly bigger way that they are
rightly contributing to the courses and
teaching learning methods and also
developing pedagogies and making their
staff available to
do that not only that now the
international domain people have started
coming in a very very big way
ibm i think started some five six years
back and then
all sorts of other players are trying to
do that
so when it comes to so-called
preparedness for job i think the answer
would be
dynamic dynamism one should acquire
diversity one should acquire and make
sure that one is ready for an
international domain earlier the local
domains or the national domain was
sufficient
now it has to be uh an international
domain for
for which one has to work so these are
certain things which i would say
which are changing but i would also say
that a recent change which is there
is that we used to say that is a
master of one and jack of all and jack
of none various other contributions for
uh combinations were there
but today uh earlier you used to survive
with that eye
shaped expertise that i'm expert in one
domain and i'll survive
but today that has become t-shaped you
need to know
a lot of other domains in addition to
your own expert domain
if you have to survive in the changing
market situation
so that's one thing and whether you are
a commerce graduate or arts graduate or
history graduate whatever it may be
i think you need to be tech savvy i
think
if i'm a history teacher today i need to
know that how do i use a concept of time
machine
to teach history to my student and then
only history
will be attractive and appealing and
then probably new
new things will come out of from from
that sort of history
so there are many things which are
changing
and if i say if engineering was
providing jobs in mechanical civil
electrical
i think those kind of jobs are vanishing
today they'll be a better job for food
engineer
they'll be better job for fire engineer
they'll be better job for fashion
engineer
and if you go to the computer domain all
these
new changes which you are probably
seeing from ai to big data to machine
learning to anything which you talked
about they are super super specialized
in
terms of cyber security or information
security or computer networks or what
are those
810 disciplines which we are talking
about so yes
specializations have retained their
place but a lot of
other characteristics or attributes are
also required
in the would be graduates uh right now
right doctor i think uh some very very
interesting points
that you mentioned uh i mean this is
something that we have
also seen firsthand being more in the
digital scaling space
and you know some of the examples that
you quoted that nascom is working on
kind of putting some structure to it so
under the future skills uh
project that they've done i think
they've mapped out around 40
50 different roles that power digital uh
verticals or i.t in general in the world
and
having skills mapped to it so i think
that's that's also a space that simply
and operates in and we
actively see that that you know people
who come in for
training post their normal education so
people who are like two years five years
experience
coming and doing one of these programs
their goal is very clear that i want to
get into this kind of a role so i'm
picking up the skills needed for that
role
but what i found very very interesting
was also your entire point about
learning to learn and that becoming the
biggest skill in the future and
especially i think what i can relate to
is that whenever there is more
uncertainty and faster
change it is the ability to adapt and
you know problem solving the basic first
principle problem solving if
people are good at then definitely they
can take something fresh thrown at them
and figure out how to kind of handle it
and
and therefore be ready for uh the future
in that sense
so one of the things i think in the
coveted scenario
uh doctor sensitive which i think a lot
of people will have on their minds is
more they said
what should they expect in the next uh
12 months 24 month
period that you know one part is the
kind of change that's happened in the
last
15 20 years and now there's this so
already there was so much change there
was technology and
business disruption and so on i mean one
example that we caught internally a lot
of times was that
a company like nokia in 2007 2008
nobody could have thought of that in
2012 that company won't be there anymore
right so that pace of change was already
there and now you have a covet kind of
scenario which
further creates that much more chaos so
in in the current climate
i mean do you see the some of the same
stuff being more critical or
do you see something new becoming uh
very important for
the graduates kind of entering the
market right now
yeah i think a whole lot of things can
be said about
this particular question one as it is
even pre-covered times
uh we have started defining everything
as pre-covered and covered and
post-covered which will anyway
will happen soon hope so today the
russians have claimed the vaccine
so we don't know how things will change
but
you know everything has become highly
non-linear that means its relationship
with its input can be different an
output can be different
yes we know the cycles many things
happens in a cyclic fashion
but the cycles have also changed some
has become faster some has become slower
and there are certain things which have
gone through a
complete phase shift of 180 degree
i can just give you an example of what
we do earlier our focus was
on covering the syllabus all the time
when we go to the class and we'll tell
students that we are covering the and
then we'll be very happy
and today the concept has completely
changed it is uncover the syllabus
uncover its potential the subject's
potential why we are teaching
where will it be used so if a static
thing like teaching domain can change so
much with 180 degree phase shift
i think the job domains will change much
much faster
and therefore the jobs have
our job specialties have a shorter time
span where you can deliver
and that is why this higher end fire has
also become very very common you can
possibly say
and therefore there are so many other
things which are possibly there as far
as the
these kind of changes but when it comes
to covet i think uh
it has shook every one of us it's a fact
that if i talk of the academic world
let's say i give you the example of the
academic world
we were not accepting technology at all
even now there is a lot of resistance by
a lot of senior people how can we do
online classes
every now and then you will see articles
coming up what will happen to sports
what will happen to eye contact what
will happen to discipline
i think whatever they may say the fate
is now casted already in terms of
technology being used so that interest
or resistance
whether it was interest or whether it
was a resistance it's all wiped off
it has to be used this is what kovid has
ensured
and therefore you can say that 10 years
back we started on what we call virtual
labs
you're talking about adoption of
technology and education
it didn't happen in a big way because
all the ingredients or building blocks
were not there
for example virtual labs were not there
the scaling part of the lab part same
with the examination part was there but
only limited only classroom activities
through smart rooms and this
and telecast and all that satellite
based experiments then
tv based dth based and then of course
web-based and all that everything was
there
but now the all things have started
appearing all of a sudden there are a
dozen vendors
who are doing vlabs virtual lives right
there are two dozen vendors who are
doing examination
who is better than each other kind of a
thing if you see their profiles
same same everything so that is what has
changed
in during kuwait times last four to six
months which are there
i would say that there is a complete new
terminology in terms of
what is post-covet times one thing which
has happened in a big way in indian
education is
we were not necessarily very good in
application research but all of a sudden
every institution
started producing masks and shields and
ventilators and
started collaborating and joining for
vaccines and all that by the way
srm is doing one of the integral part of
this
biotech vaccine which india is
developing already in the second stage
of trial
so all of a sudden when we are not
collaborating with each other we have
started collaborating with each other
we were competitive fine but this one
plus one in hindi we used to say eleven
yara
that was not happening one plus one even
two was not happening in boolean you
have one plus one
is also one even that was not happening
our one plus one was
actually zero because we were having the
same magnitude but opposite directions
when we are collaborating so those
things have changed in a very big way
uh another thing which has changed post
covered times in my opinion
is about the society itself society has
understood
the nature better societies understood
the importance of
efficiently utilizing the resources be
teaching beat education be
time eat anything that's another thing
which is changing and then of course
i must tell you uh that a lot of my
senior colleagues
in educational profession didn't
probably
know even the word sdgs the sustainable
development goals which are 17 in
numbers and we started with some smaller
number earlier
those were not prevailing those were not
known and now all of a sudden
everyone is talking about that and
trying to do something
so you can say that and another thing is
application orientation and local
orientation
is also creeping in with the covet which
is there
and of course when you talk of family so
you can take different aspects of
transportation or whatever you can say
when you talk of family the changes are
far too many
that family is now a priority the work
life parameters
wise you have better control because you
are now with your family
you take care of them and therefore
meaning of life has changed
and and then one one concept you can say
that
that earlier we were
[Music]
probably putting ourselves in a category
work
to live okay and now we
probably live to work this kind of
concept has changed
okay so uh you you can say that live to
work
means if i'm i'm there i'm surviving
i'll have to keep working
now i it's the other way around that i
basically work to live so some concepts
are changing in a very very
big way post coverage times and i'm sure
this change would be permanent that's
the
importance of it right now education
which was slow moving with the
technology
has suddenly uh adopted it like fish
will be in the water
it has it has seen that as a right
medium
right platform right space technology
has become integral part of the
education
so is the case now with the industry
also so is the case with the service
sector
that they are all technologically
dependent
i think that's very interesting uh dr
sensitive i was reading one research and
kind of forgetting the name of the
person whose quote i'm
kind of using here uh if i'm not wrong
it's paul
paul something that so the prediction is
more this that covet has accelerated
one decade of change in education uh in
one year
so which was pretty phenomenal
phenomenal to
uh see that that whether it's transition
to virtual labs or virtual assessment or
using technology and multimedia and
ensuring better
education and so many different things
that are possible
so it's really good to see that adoption
happening and then that change
accelerating
um one of the other things uh which i i
just want to
maybe a kind of a follow-up question is
for this that this particular social
transition that as
as we get into the covet scenario and
people are finding lot more time at home
and with family or with themselves and
so on
and that influencing the choice of
career so
career is always a function of two
things that you know what is
what is the job available and what do i
want to do
so it was more than that for a very very
long time that what do i want to do was
always as a
you know something at the back it's more
obviously okay you know i'll get a job
as an id
software programmer or as a sales or
marketing guy or as an
ops professional so it's more that let
me just fit into it
this is the place where jobs are there
so i'm just going to go and fit myself
over there
so but you are saying that that is also
changing when people have a more clear
idea about what they want to do
and so perhaps this is also possible
because
the market is opening up to new niche
roles and
new kind of career options that perhaps
never existed and
so so do you could you add some thoughts
on that that
you know compared to much earlier now in
the covet situation or
what what kind of niche roles uh i'm
also seeing
one or two questions on the gig economy
uh coming up
so how do you see that and how do you
see graduates may be
thinking about that that are some people
having career aspirations in a slightly
different direction then it's not the
standard software job or management job
but it's it's something different that
they want to do and there is scope to do
that now
yeah so as as i said
the advancement has changed the complete
scenario one
probably because of the prosperity
or the overall economic growth the
dependence of the
young graduates their families on the
young graduates is not there
so people can experiment with certain
things
uh so that is why people have become
inspirational for example
earlier you would be all aspiring to get
a good job but today you are aspiring to
be an entrepreneur you are yourself an
entrepreneur
and that happens only when when you have
some safety built in
so one is that there are many tracks
earlier it was a job
and now there are many tracks tracks can
be that you can be an entrepreneur and
i'm seeing
uh from any let's say i take engineering
as an example
whether you want to be a fashion
designer or whether you want to be a
filmmaker or actor
or a sports person engineers are going
to all domain and same is the case with
all that so
after doing your engineering you may not
be necessarily looking for engineering
as a carrier
and you may be right from the beginning
looking at this so three years or four
years of degree doesn't make
much of difference in my opinion but
still engineering is a professional
degree
and therefore it gives you that
empowerment that you can do
secondly uh the world is seeing a
technological shift right from the
beginning
from the inception or or the invention
of appeal to
to various other things which were there
maybe the wars were fought because of
that
and what's stopped because of that
second world war was because of the
atomic bomb
and so is the case with technology
everywhere so technology prevails
in terms of those changes at computer
and had the
internet not been there you probably
would have seen the same traditional
world
i say that that was probably first
generation but
internet may be second generation and
now all that cybernetics and all that
ai and all that may be third fourth
generation the family is growing fast
and once the family or the generations
change
the aspects of working also change
today we know that how young kids behave
and they take their own decisions
we were over dependent on our parents
that is the reason why you can possibly
say
that everything is changing the the
other thing is the opportunities
are there some professions are not
considered to be
good earlier or some directions of
job or assignments are not considered to
be good but today you can
excel in fact you can make more money
you can get instant recognition
one example which i can say to you which
is not necessarily education
when i was young maybe you even when you
were young
your parents and relatives must have
told you that
i think it's once again a complete shift
i think if i have to be at 16 years
earning crores and becoming world famous
it's
sports is the only route even the
bollywood will not help
hollywood not will not help me in that
so
all those things actually what what
basically i'm trying to indicate to you
is uh
that everything where you can deliver
some expert value
is uh is what is uh what is uh
accepted by the market uh uh i find many
many uh
tough families from where the kids are
going into hotel industry
they want to be a chef and and and
create something which
anyways the need of the mankind all the
time we
we try to eat something different and
and that's what we fancy most
and therefore people are going to that
sort of a domain so what i'm saying is
the
world is getting flattened already we
are talking about that flattening is not
because of the communication alone
threatening is every job every
profession every profile
has the same importance and within the
jobs and the profile or the
specialization every person has some
utility
and some key feature and therefore
it's flattening in that particular sense
therefore people are accepting
jobs the way they are coming or whatever
way they are
happening and and therefore the newness
is also happening in the jobs
right so it's very interesting i
i think one thing that this kind of
links up to is basically more
you know as people explore different
things and different options rather than
being very
straight jacketed and looking at only
the three or four carrier options that
we had maybe 20 years back
one of the things that i think briefly
what we were discussing earlier as well
that
this entire shift between hiring for
aptitude and hiring for skill
um how how does this play out and and
how should a
let's say a graduate who's kind of
looking at his first job or
setting up a career uh how does he get
ready for
that because there are some careers
where people
their companies hire for aptitude and
there are some careers where
the skill becomes very important um that
do you know the specific technology or
do you know the specific
area then then the job opens up so in
in some sense is there some kind of
balance over there that
as a institute how do you prepare people
for this kind of shuffle that keeps
happening
this is something very difficult one
because the young minds are
sometimes not fully frozen in terms of
what their aspirations are
what they want to become in life and as
they move along from first year to
second year to whatever
things keep changing i have met many
people
when you probe them you find that every
five minutes their answer will change
and that's one reason why
it's something difficult to deliver to
them second reason of course i have told
you
industry is also changing very rapidly
changing
so once again the outcomes or
expectations are also changing
so uh uh educational system is a little
at
loss how to deal with that its effect of
life so in in the process what we try to
do
is uh to overcome all these challenges
is try to deliver them
a large number of things and we
generally expect that they themselves
will be
taking a final call where to do better
than the other domains where they don't
want to
focus much and therefore we try to
deliver them
a lot of with openness
many things and this openness is going
to increase
extensively very soon this new education
policy has been announced
and in that we are going to make it a
student-centric that means a student can
take
three subjects three majors from one
from ours one from commerce and one from
engineering or medical
and still make his or her own degree the
reason for that
is the domains are changing the
expectations are changing
so uh what one can say is
subject or content or specialization is
one aspect which i'm talking of
but then there are many other general
attributes which one should
have and number one is that they should
develop the self-learning ability
number two they should have something in
their pts skills because
stills skills will always make you
survive in your life
today there cannot be a life without a
skill in my opinion
and therefore we should kind of focus on
that
and we should also possibly you can say
that
that int shaped which i've said that you
have to be
having your specialization somewhere and
the
knowledge of various other things is
something very important
but if you can acquire the attribute of
what you call a little bit of
research or analytics or logical
abilities
which are little deeper they work well
in every situation because today even
customer is
not giving you orders for a standard
product
if you are manufacturing something you
may have to manufacturing the same
product with 10 different
variations smaller variations so unless
you can apply yourself
and do something i think it will not be
customer centric in that particular case
so
once again whether you have a skill or
whether you have the knowledge or
whether you are good in design or
perception or whatever something
i think you need to have a bigger base
and therefore if i give you an example
of electronic
you can say domain when we
graduate the engineers we will not
graduate them
as a fixed device or a sensor or vlsi or
ulsi or whatever that may be
we actually make them as as a wafer
it may be six inch wafer it may be five
inch way for eight inch wafer it may
have the
the smoothness or the required the
finishing of certain kind
on which one can always grow a device
which may be transistor or a diode or a
sensor or anything
that means we make sure that the student
acquires
all the concerned abilities fortunately
many outside agencies are also helping
us with those certifications
those traits and we engage them in a big
way
and also make sure that in the process
our students learn but our teachers also
learn
so that if there are difficulties they
can be helped and in long run if we like
them and students like them
we embed them in our courses that's
another reason why
industry people today sit in our alumni
those who are in profession for last
four five six ten years
sit in all our committees uh to make
sure that such inputs are brought in
so you can say that uh once again
education is getting flattened
to a certain extent specializations are
done by the students by way of their
project
by way of their seminar by way of their
internship but otherwise
i would expect today every graduate to
learn and know
a lot about computers whether you are
from mining domain or mechanical domain
or aeronautical domain
i think you should know that so that is
how we are trying to
uh probably counter the situation you
can say little bit of freedom
a little bit of diversity and these are
the
answers we have in our domain we have we
have not yet perfected that by the way
got it no but i think this is very very
interesting so i mean
one thing that i am taking away out of
this is that so
it's more that some of these critical
ingredients
which actually adds up to aptitude that
learning to learn
um or having that first principle
thought process to problem solve that
basically you can
apply yourself to something new and do
something meaningful with it
i think that somewhere is foundational
then picking up a skill
so if you if you've learned how to learn
or you know how to do problem solving
you inherently have developed some level
of confidence
that you can attack a new problem and
you'll do something sensible
then you have the ingredients to pick up
the skills that will
right so in some sense then on the
scaling side there are so many other
options which can complement the formal
education system
that you have nascom's future scale
initiative or you have
uh companies like simply learn who have
very well designed skill based programs
which align to
careers um so so there are a lot of
options if the foundational
aptitude is in place that people know
how to learn they know how to apply
themselves they have the confidence to
get into a unknown area and kind of
do that then they'll they'll have enough
resources out there to figure out the
skills needed to
get their career uh moving in the right
direction
yeah so so in some sense i think that's
that's very valuable
yeah you can actually relate it to that
uh
today you are seeing in your life many
things uh uh
which are unforeseen as you move along
and therefore the answers lie in partly
research type of functioning
that you explore like you you do a
journey
a long journey or you are you are doing
the mountaineering or whatever
what kind of challenges you will face at
what point
and with what intensity is not never
predictable i think the same is the
situation
all that aptitude problem solving
skills and maybe team working skills as
i was trying to tell you critical
thinking skills
uh various skills which are of people's
management or coordinating with others
or
uh maybe emotional intelligence or maybe
societal connect
today anything you do in your life if if
you
do not have the societal connect even
that probably would go wrong
a quick decision making is something
very very important
a lot of people pay the huge price when
they don't make the decision in time
maybe a little bit of uh going away from
self orientation will also help so these
are some of the attributes
which help you as you move along in your
life as you are rightly saying that
challenges are plenty and uh answers are
not unique right now
that's their bishop i think that that's
very interesting i mean i think there's
so much
more that we can discuss i mean it is a
very fascinating subject in terms of how
uh somebody gears up for a successful
career uh but but i mean these are some
very very interesting
uh you know kind of directional thoughts
for anybody to think about
i mean i can relate to it personally as
well because you know somewhere
what i think back about my graduation
days in iit bombay
is more than said it was more the
variety of things that i was able to get
myself
involved in which led to the basic
confidence that if there is something
new
then i'll be able to apply myself and do
something um so somewhere
even the educational direction that you
mentioned about the
new education policy that we'll be
implementing where
a person could take different electives
and throw himself outside of his comfort
zone
rather than just learning one thing over
and over again uh picking up
different things and putting yourself in
a different situation
i think that's where in some sense maybe
that confidence and that aptitude
building happens
um so i think that's very very
interesting so uh dr sanchez
in now if if all of these i mean we
we've discussed some stuff about the
market
and what leads to getting somebody ready
with the
right aptitude and skills and so on how
do we now translate it in terms of like
a
guidance to somebody who's let's say a
modern graduate who's
thinking about let's say in a year or so
he'll be looking at his career
and getting into his first job or
something that
what what kind of guidance do you look
at that you know maybe
top top areas that somebody should focus
on so that
is best equipped for the market that you
see
that's something uh a challenge but
this is what we do very often uh in our
profession a lot of young graduate
young would-be graduates entering into
institutions will come and seek our
opinion
when they have done 12 or plus 2 level i
think
it's it's not an easy job but what one
should do
is it's always in your life a process
called process of
selection and elimination you have to
see what is your benchmark what is your
goal
what is your dream and what are your
current set of conditions starting point
always decides the
the the end point of optimization called
life
okay life is nothing but an optimization
you may earn more money but you may not
have their family
you may have both family and this but
you are still confined because of
certain threats
that you cannot enjoy go out bollywood
people can't go out very easily in
public and enjoy that
they have money in fame and name you
need to decide
what is your aspiration
and a young mind as a if they can do it
early it's
better for them for example i find lot
of engineering graduates
would be graduates coming now i want
only x discipline
whereas when you ask them they want to
become a civil servant and that ex
discipline has nothing to do with that
particular
uh branch anyway or ies or maybe civil
services same way
when everyone is trying to get into an
mba degree immediately after engineering
i generally tend to tell them that go
for the easiest branch of engineering
whatever in your opinion
you like let us say mathematics and all
that probably computer and electronics
will be better
like physics and all that possibly
mechanical and production and
aeronautical things will be better
you will possibly like chemistry then
and biology kind of a thing
and chemical genetics and all that
biotechnology and all that can be better
but if that is the aim
but if they want to become an mba
immediately after this in continuation
there is no point in worrying about the
branch
so in terms of guidance it's a bit
difficult
to extract those points and then it has
to be person-centric it cannot be
universal that everyone can become
electronics or computer engineering
and that's one thing which i would
probably try to tell
so number one make a target today
and make sure that your target is moving
target
in case you want to move it and
therefore you can follow reorient
yourself correct yourself
i'll give you an example possibly in the
end that how would i
try to help a young graduate through
technology
maybe in in the end that which
a human being or a counselor like us
cannot do it easily very easily
so that's one aspect that take those
risks
number one you should understand that uh
failure and successes are the two sides
of the same coin
and if the coin is unbiased the
probability of failure and success is
same
so we have to make sure that we have to
bias that coin
and bias it in such a way that the
success rate becomes more than the
failure rate
however we should also accept that the
failure is bound to come
one was trying to get rid of failure by
running away from it
is not a good thing which i would say
failure would be there
i think in every successful man's or
person's life
you have seen the failures which are
there of course they get documented much
later and come to more much later but
if we understand this concept easily or
earlier
i think it would be better so with
knowledge acquiring knowledge
or a wisdom or whatever you can say
today's
context i think we bias that coin
ourselves we are the coin right now we
bias ourselves with
that knowledge so that our successes are
more than our
failures this is what we need to do but
we are still followable
we cannot be succeeding and that is the
reason why
in entrepreneurship domain as people say
there are no
clear statistics 9 out of 10 startups
don't
necessarily go beyond a certain time or
go beyond a certain level so uh failures
are an integral part of that
accept that change directions gears
don't feel shy
when the problems are there when the
successes are there
share it by sharing also it will go and
by if if you are doing good sharing it
it will grow
and when you are failing and when you
share it it will go
both the things will happen and
therefore people should not confine
everything to themselves they should
open up and that is how
i think they can make their life and
they can go ahead
that is what i would possibly say
that that will change so
and and also as you move along uh if you
need certain attributes to be developed
um acquire them uh while you are on fly
and that's that's something very
important depending upon others to serve
you
on that uh possibly can be an answer
when you scale it up
but for you to know the basics of that
would be something very important
and that is how you can say an example
of
what i was saying for sharing we do
patenting
now a lot of people by patenting or ip
think
we are trying to keep our things secret
i think the concept is once again an
entirely 180 degree shift by doing
patenting you are making sure your
commercial interest
but otherwise you're publishing
everything which you do under that
patent
you're telling the world this is what i
can create this is how i create this is
the process
and please make use of it the whole
patenting is nothing but
commercialization
commercialization happens only when you
talk to public therefore
talk to people talk to pro develop
processes
as do whatever such things which are
there which is what is not taught in
india
generally speaking and the world
otherwise has
done outside world has done that
slightly well better than us
and therefore this change has to happen
in our case is what i would suggest
right it's a very interesting point i
mean i think on the last point that you
were mentioning i mean
there are so many times where there will
be some you know
early stage entrepreneur who will come
and discuss and he'll be very very
afraid about telling his idea to anyone
and you know it takes a lot of time for
us to mentor him saying that
nobody is going to copy your idea you
can rest assured that you know maybe
four other people are thinking of the
same idea
it's more about execution so i mean on
this patent side the fear of
kind of sharing it with the world i mean
so you can
you know take care of your commercial
interest but after that i think only
when you share
then the ecosystem builds around it and
i think everybody benefits
so that's that's really interesting uh
so so
i think you know more for somebody who's
again looking at their first career and
and first job one of the things that i
also
heard you say is more around this entire
fear of failure
and i think maybe one idea that i would
add to it from
you know something that i've seen and
would love to hear if you also
experience this is that when people are
thinking about their first job or first
career there are
lot of very very short-term milestones
which because they do not have the
larger
idea about what a career is like they
attach
way too much importance so for example
you know lot of the
motivation going behind a particular
kind of job that pays the highest out of
campus
whereas the reality is more than that
you know the what makes a successful
career is that
you're doing something that your
aptitude is in and you don't hit a glass
ceiling
so how long can you go without hitting a
glass ceiling right so
so a lot of times graduates struggle
with this concept so
a lot of focus will go into this key
okay i got a five lakh job he got a
seven lakh job and that's the definition
of success
uh not realizing that it's a long race
and i think you have to set yourself up
for success by saying that
i'm strong at these areas let me build a
career in this direction
and more likely to succeed so
love to hear if you you've seen some
thoughts around this uh
as well yeah i mean
these things are obviously
uh you can say your base level decides
which background you come from
you come from a poor family you come
from a family which is from rural
background
you have not seen the world outside i
must tell you my own story that
when i went for my phd to uk as a
congress scholar i had that huge fear in
my mind that
i'm a non-entity and i will not be able
to survive
kind of a thing and and and uh
i saw people with an awe especially the
people from the western or advanced
world
and uh it's only the exposure there of
just a month
my first day was a very scary day for me
the
second day i thought i'm failing i'm not
doing this and that
i didn't know how to operate a server
and i was trying to figure out various
things and
you know a unique machine which i had
not seen here
i'm saying early 90s 1991 like that
and within a month things changed
entirely that i became an indispensable
person for the entire group
for everything they needed they started
harping on me and coming so sometimes
the exposure will
change things in you so people should
get good exposure and that is what
through variety of
schemes we are trying for example in
education setup now students have
brought program we are trying to do all
these internships we are trying to do
the faculty is internships so that fear
will go away
but i would still say that fear is also
a new knowledge
fear means the failure with fear and all
that i'm saying failure is also new
knowledge if i've done something
with regard with intensity and with
interest
and proper planning and still failed and
if i document it
i'm sure that this will be a new
knowledge qualified for research
publication and
still entertainment and not only an
attainment when people will read it
and they find that you have attempted
such things they will come back to you
connect with you
use your expertise and join hands with
you if we have this answer and we can do
it
so you will again act as a catalyst in
doing something new
therefore there are various ways in
which you can always convert negatives
into positives
or loss to a profit or loss out of
profit
all that can be done you have to have
the positive outlook
uh our biggest challenge in india is
b class or c class cities or rural
cities the exposure is not enough
so all institutions should make sure
that all industries should make sure
that all ecosystem should make sure that
proper exposure is given if i say if i
compare and i used to compare because i
have headed many nits by the way
and i used to compare at that time as i
had what is the difference between an
iit and nit
okay why iit is seen to be an iit and by
the way my son
anderson was also an idw student we used
to have some discussions
over this that why are you different why
are we different
and we find the biggest thing was this
exposure only
there the people are craving the noble
audits are coming the experts are coming
the ceos are coming
talking chatting and just exploring
or trying to deliver new things and
whereas in a conventional institution we
are purely focusing on the
core education or the subject only so i
would say that
everyone can succeed there are many many
success stories i need not name
indian ceos are there everywhere in the
world top 10 top 20 companies
you see many of them are indians and
they all come from ordinary background
if you see sundar pichai i i think
if you try to ask someone to take
metallurgy today is going to curse you
sundar pichai has gone from metallurgy
to wherever if you ask someone like
satya nadella to go back to an ordinary
institution at that time manipal was new
and young
today of course it's very good but uh
people will try to say no i want to go
to only iit or isc or whatever it may be
but then we have all come from that
ordinary background
and therefore india should start
believing in what our potential is
we have we are very hard working brief
we are intelligent
we are multilingual we can adopt to a
given situation whether it is food
living language whatever it may be that
is why we are succeeding
and therefore i don't i don't see
we not encashing this particular uh
upcoming
uh uh changes in our favor
indians will be omnipresent and
graduates of all kinds are going to do
very well is what i think now dr sanchez
i think on that very very positive note
uh you know i i completely
you know agree with that that i think
the biggest thing that our graduates can
do is that if they
enter life with a very positive state of
mind and with confidence
i'm sure that they all have the skills
to kind of build a great career for
themselves
but maybe in interest of time i think
i'll move to some of the
questions that have come from the
audience and maybe we can
share our thoughts around that
so one question that i
see here is
do you think that the industry still
attaches greater significance to degree
qualifications than to
short courses and informal learning uh
i think that's one of the questions
we've got
on the group so yeah as of now it's true
uh and and not only that that they are
attaching it to degree they are
attaching it to a degree from a reputed
or a known institution
also as i said from an ordinary
institution
also a good guy can come i gave you the
example of satya nadella at that time
he was not in iit or rec yet he has
risen to whatever level
and therefore industry is currently
attaching that to that and they have
their own accreditation systems and do
that
but it's opening up you know that some
of the top companies like google's and
all that
possibly have people from age of 14
15 years being consultants or being
whatever
disruptors or thought process
changing change makers and all that so
it's getting accepted in my opinion uh
talent
ultimately talent or skill will prevail
industries uh are not necessarily going
to follow that path for long
in our own setup if you see tcs as an
example
i would say that tcl started taking for
the
the conventional entry-level jobs for
which they hire a lot of people
they started taking bscs and therefore
bsc computer science or bsc
something like information science or
data science is happening
on the other side educational
institutions iisc never offered
i'm a board member there so i'm saying
that they never offered earlier anything
other than postgraduate program but
today they are offering ug program also
iit for example never offered a three
year undergraduate program but there i
i t chennai has started something on
data science very recently
so the change is happening and uh but
one has to prove his or her skill
the challenge here right now is that you
don't get chance to prove that once
for one post there are 10 20
applications let's say
then uh an initial filtering becomes an
essential thing
and the easy filtering criteria is look
at the qualification and that's where
sometimes the skill loses out or they
don't get an opportunity to showcase
what they have in their kitty
and so that's uh you can say bias we
have in the system
but hopefully it will change that's my
expectation
right so i i would also add to that i
think what what
we have also seen in practice is more
than said the professional degree
and you know the kind of academic uh
qualifications that somebody has had
it's always a very strong indicator of
you know the amount of dedication that
the person had right so the person
was not relaxed he did not kind of leave
it loose and kind of have a bad
academic career but beyond that lot of
the new age jobs and
you know it finally boils down to how a
person proves himself in the
assessment or interview or group
discussion and so on
so i think it's more that the
professional degree and having a good
academic qualification is kind of
baseline
if you don't have that baseline then it
gets more difficult
but beyond that then it becomes more how
you are applying yourself and
obviously if you have some skills which
are being sought off in the market then
it becomes a
sweet sweetener in that sense it is that
much easier to
kind of get the right kind of job
we still are very traditional i i'll
just give an example
the same person or sandeep can
teach the course to an individual and
give a degree with srm or some name
the same person is teaching outside srm
and not giving the degree but giving the
same education the problem here is
right that that is not valued though the
person may be equally competent the same
thing happens let's say in consultancy
i give you consultancy and i give it in
my name that sandeep sanchez says that
you may like it but the moment i say
that no this iit is saying that and from
iit sandeep sanjit is signing that
i think the value changes so that's how
the world has
moved initially but for sure it's going
to change
there are many coders there are many
developers many apprisers or
whatever they are not necessarily from
the same set of qualifications but
they have done wonders so a word is
accepting them
even without degrees okay
correct absolutely i think uh
moving on so we have a question on
so there is a person who has a mba in
travel and tourism as a sector
and in the prevailing situation there is
a complete disruption of
these industries so
so so for an individual looking at a
career in that sector
how should we approach i think this is a
very unique case in in
some sense uh i don't know if there's
so would you have some thoughts on this
uh not the best but i i would say that
this is one
one uh uh expert domain uh which
i liked it always uh hotel management
and tourism and travel
uh as uh we become economically sound we
tend to
take more advantage of that but kovid
has only put
it in a slight difficulty and this is
one sector which is facing the biggest
music
right now but as i said uh
there will be failures in your system
not necessarily by your
own design but because of the other
things or the nature which is there
please take them in your stride i'm i'm
every day or every second day i'm
craving to go out and eat outside and
visit this place and that place in my
own
current situation and therefore i'm
pretty sure
the moment covet vaccine is there and
the situation is normal
there will be a spurt of activities
and the redemption of what you call
their travel and tourism sector
so you have to have the patience till
that time
however till that time either you can
take some sundry job and still survive
but if you don't want there are many
things in life which we
you can do to fulfill yourself be it in
the sports domain
be it reading certain new things be it
helping and already running set up in
your family without worrying about the
cost and the remuneration and all that
so that you learned that
i think these things sometimes can be
god given things i've seen in my own
life my cousins and friends
that they failed in something they had
time in hand and they were probably
something happened
someone learned more about agriculture
someone learned more about uh
even homeopathy and all that and that
has changed their life okay because they
got time to do all that
so you should not despair is my advice
to
the young friend who is seeking uh
answer to this particular thing
this is going to come with a bank and
once it comes
back i think it's going to be equally
rewarding and it will compensate for all
the losses which has happened
because this is an inherent nature of
mankind
to move out and to look at the places to
to
eat different foods and all that
therefore this sector is
uh bound to do well i think that's very
well said
i mean a lot of times we discuss about
this right now in poverty situation it's
always
push and pull between desperation and
fear so we are all in the house because
we are afraid of uh you know catching
this but there's always a
part of us that is pushing us saying
that it's enough let's get out now
so it's just a matter of time
yeah but so moving to one
other uh question which is very specific
and uh i mean it's
is bca versus engineering which is
better
and this is something dr sanjati
the answer is not need not be given by
me right now
uh the new education policy is already
giving an
answer if you have read that those
headlines probably you see that a
three-year degree or four-year degree
can be given by the same institution
in the same domain depending upon the
student's choice
if you think in a three-year degree
you've undertaken good projects good
internships good innovations you're done
i would say even without degree you will
be wonderful and i'll be
person like me will be ready to employ
uh
such person who can deliver goods in a
given circumstances so
uh why three year and four year
comparison
there are cases where we find even after
masters they don't
mend their ways and they still remain as
fuzzy and as
you can say ordinary and they don't get
gain anything
so the number of years put in is not
very important
the level acquired is very important i
like those people
who very clearly understand what they
want to achieve in life
okay a bca route can lead you to a
certain starting point
after that your performance in that
first job will count and take you
further
in iit sector bc obviously is related to
yt sector
i think uh there is there is nothing
called
uh an essential requirement of a degree
as long as you are able to deliver i.t
sector when
it was in its initial phase and in boom
i think a lot of body shopping was
happening i know that a lot of graduates
of bcaa bsc were
being picked up from the institution as
long as they had the
they required skill sets and therefore
my answer is three year and four year is
no difference even injuring and
non-engineering
is no difference anyone can do the same
thing
provided they have the skills in hand we
see lot of
novel designs a lot of grassroot
innovation level
things happen outside engineering
students
people from rural background people who
are working in the field they create
many unique things
and therefore an engineering degree is
not essential for surviving in life
for sure though i am an engineer i love
engineering but to engineer
being an engineer you can only say that
you can create new things
as a bca also or as a vba also you can
create many new things
dba can create new processes very easily
you can create
new codes new languages new approaches
new algorithms
maybe new protocols everything you can
do nothing stops you that's what i would
say
that's great so there is there are
three or four related questions and i
think these are very specific on
specific technologies and uh trends that
what what is
scaling so dr sanchez may be i'll i'll
just share
a few uh answers to that and then we'll
come back to one question that's
specifically for you um so i i'm seeing
a question
on you know data science that uh will
there be good demand for data science
after the
covet pandemic and then there are
similar questions for ai
cloud computing and uh programming so
so maybe i'll i'll try to answer that uh
together
and uh dr century you can add uh you
know
what what do you feel about it but so i
think one thing that we are seeing very
strongly
is that you know what has the
pandemic done i think what it has done
is that it has pushed a whole lot of
time of mankind in general on to
internet or on devices um so earlier if
we had lot of interaction in an office
space or
outside um i think a lot of that time is
going into these devices and as a result
a lot of these technologies are seeing
that hockey sticker that they are seeing
a boom
uh which is unprecedented and
accelerating many years of growth into
this short period of time so
there is a data report that we were
looking at that
the amount of data consumption in one
month in u.s
with a lot of this data is more easily
available has shorter by 67
because people are spending so much more
time on the internet and
on their devices and and so on that 67
growth in data consumption so now
automatically this translates into
growth in sectors like data science
sectors like artificial intelligence and
so on right um
i think another related stat is what
does it does everybody works from home
and interacts from home
everything that we are doing is on the
cloud so companies who had a
internet and you could be and you could
access it only when you are in office
they have been forced to open it up to
the cloud so again that translates into
crazy growth for cloud and cloud
technologies and so on
and i think similarly internet and
programming and all digital technologies
in fact another thing that we have seen
uh dr sinchiti a huge boom in his
cyber security i think this you were
also mentioning that uh
as everybody is accessing stuff from
home cyber security becomes so much more
critical
so i think one broad answer to you know
everybody
who's asked these 405 related questions
is that
i mean we are definitely seeing this
trend that as
you know as this pandemic pans out lot
of the digital tech is going through
very rapid growth and obviously there
are more jobs getting created there as
well
um so so see i mean that
that's a few points on that front i
i'll supplement your answer uh here by
saying that
uh sometimes back for a webinar when i
was going through i
came across uh maybe
top 10 or top eight or whatever
declining or
you know emerging roles kind of a thing
and if i see those domains basic
and infrastructure consumer aside
energy side financial services side
healthcare
information communication technology
mobility and professional services
the job profile which is taking the
biggest shape or which is emerging in
all these sectors put together
is related to computer and software
engineering is finding number one or
number two in
most of them out of these eight names
which i've given to you
if you see what do they need at number
one or number two
either it's a software engineering or
computer engineering or something of
that kind of a thing
is available and therefore i said it in
one of the answers which i was trying to
cover
that today whatever you may do you may
be an arts person or history person or
commerce person
or you may not be any person in terms of
education
but you still need to know the basics of
all these what we call the computer and
the i.t
and the services rendered because that's
how you survive in the life today the
banking
has completely become like that
entertainment has become completely
through that
and various other things in your life
will be through iot and connected these
things your own parameters of your life
will be communicated to you
by these devices and you have to
interpret them and do
and therefore this sector is going to
grow whether you call it big data or
small data or biggest data doesn't
matter
it is going to remain uh for foreseeable
future
right so i think one last question
dr sanjati which i have here is more
around
you know so somebody from a non-tech
background uh
aspiring towards a career in the
technology field and
perhaps i'll make it slightly more
generic that you know a lot of the stuff
that we have discussed about is more
around
alignment of education and you know the
job market
so this is a very interesting question
that you know if let's say a person
specializes in one field
and lot of times we get into a
graduation without complete
think through that what do i want to do
in life so if i if i've graduated in one
area
and then i'm aspiring towards another
area uh how do i navigate and
you know is it is it difficult and what
can i do to compensate i think that's
the
more generic form of the question okay
my answer is uh nothing to worry about
because
this is an age where multidisciplinarity
trans disciplinarity interdisciplinarity
does not differentiate between them
is highly highly desirable or acceptable
for example the world will think
patenting is a very very technical job
whereas truly speaking this has to be
done by
a lawyer more than a technical person
technical person will innovate and do
something but when it comes to
taking it in shape of patent is done by
a person of that nature
you may do a lot of technology i may do
but i may still do a poor design of my
hardware in terms of its utility be
chair or be it my laptop or whatever a
designer will come
a designer maybe from arts or performing
arts or
or whatever whatever that science it may
be
i think when i use and write certain
instructions and all that
the linguistics and people with those
kind of background
would be very very handy when i'm using
it and when i'm communicating what is
right and wrong the people with
psychology background will come into
play
therefore you'll find that whether i'm
from technology background and i'm
manufacturing all that i'll still have
to hire such
people who have those pieces of
knowledge
to make my product worthwhile for
general public
and therefore there is a space for
everyone when it comes to marketing i
need not tell what kind of attributes
you require
a lot of communication skills which are
require a lot of reasoning etc which
will require a lot of
some special things so tell me uh i can
ask that gentleman or you can give me an
answer
which is that attribute which is paining
someone i'm saying
everything sells today everything has a
utility today
in my opinion everything is
cross-connected you are
not now living in a silo corridor i know
my
programming and therefore i am the best
now if i cannot
explain and categorize my code and exp
and and make people understand that code
has no value
because in next one month when it is to
be moderated and changed upon
it cannot be done because i am not good
at that so writing basic things
doing basic things will not be very fine
and therefore my strong advice is
this is a nice thing that you come from
a different background
and still help a technology background
or any other background
and therefore there is a cross
connection and
very well acceptable to me this is
the boundary which is getting fuzzy
new knowledge new research new
development is all happening there
by the way to support that answer i
would say that
recently some councils and regulatory
bodies
have made it compulsory that all new
courses which one would be allowed to
start
will have to have multi-disciplinary in
nature
no traditional things will be started or
allowed to be started it has to have
multi-disciplinary
so the question raised here is also
about the
different disciplines and different
disciplines
and therefore it's very well acceptable
success route to
any particular position or level is not
necessarily through
one part and here i'd like to give one
example which i was trying to
tell you that i'll give you in the end
and that
to be the best you need not be
necessarily coming from that particular
domain
we know that a lot of top people need
not have done computer engineering but
they are the best in the computer domain
right now
or so would be the case in any other
industry domain uh whatever way you can
say
and therefore route to success uh is
from any direction any field anyway
times may differ
maybe the uh the efforts may differ and
therefore
i am of the opinion the kind of activity
which we are trying to do is to guide
our young
students in this challenging world that
how do they make their career
now this is very subjective because i
would not know my client very well his
background very well
whereas your systems the current i.t
systems or database systems can possibly
capture that very easily
over a period of years and keep guiding
me so like
we have what we call a gps
the global positioning system so if i
want to go from position a to position b
in a city
i i give my current position my data and
all that and i give
the position or the coordinates of the
name of the other position
and i get 10 different answers and in 10
different answers i get 10 different
values of let's say congestion or cost
or time or whether i'm
better by car or by motorcycle or by
cycle or whatever
everything comes to me all the options
and that is nothing but a guidance
i think something like this is required
for carrier building of the young people
because the parameters are far too many
and therefore
and it's all a non-linear optimization
in terms of what you want to achieve or
get right and therefore i would suggest
that and i've suggested this openly
a couple of forums here and there
particularly in a microsoft conference
last year i did share that that we
should have like gps
a thing called spg students personal
guidance system
being developed where students will
constantly feed his or her data from
aids or mind content standard
and based on various successes
attainments failures
interest records performances it will
get
and finally when he or she comes to a
stage where he wants a decision he will
say okay
after 10 years i want to become
let's say bill gates or 20 years bill
gates or i want to become
bill clinton or i want to become steve
jobs or i want to be whatever whatever
they want to say
they will feed that and this system
based on that big data and artificial
intelligence and my basic information
based level data
you'll be able to guide the person so
you will become self-dependent you will
get the help of the data you will have
many ample of cases to tell you the
success and failure stories
and it will also tell you the cost
whether you will reach there or not what
will be the risk involved what are the
ways to
improve your chances which skill to
acquire to improve your chances to reach
there
now i may not be knowing best of the
skills every time or who is delivering
it but that database will have all that
information
and that can give it so therefore i
would say that
these kind of systems are going to be
available and these go these kind of
systems are going to make sure that
everyone benefits from this new tag and
all this
whatever is available to us through
through our ai and all that
and we can give get personalized
guidance
tailored to our requirements that is
what can happen
and however one should make sure that
your starting point is a very good
starting point
optimized point and then obviously the
the success of that optimization will
become much better
once the starting point is right i think
that's very very interesting in fact
that's a
startup idea right there if somebody
wants to build it
so but just one comment that i wanted to
add for the person who's asked this
question is also that
you know i think it at an early stage
whatever be the career or whatever be
the degree that you have gotten to but
if you are
if you discovered a passion for
something that you want to do i think
that itself is the biggest asset
so i mean there's a example about so my
brother-in-law himself he has a degree
in commerce so he's
done a b com but then he's basically
built a carrier in it
so he's a software architect now and
obviously it was comparatively difficult
i mean if you're a software
engineer by degree and then you move
into that so computer science to
software engineer is easier
but he's been able to navigate that and
i think what really made it happen for
it for him was his passion and he was
very clear that that's what he wanted to
do in life and there are very few people
uh you know who have that kind of
clarity uh early on in their career
so i would more compliment the person
that if you're clear about what you want
to do
more more likely than not you'll get
there so
right so same thing would be true for
game developers
you have to be a gamer and then only you
can code it
if you just know the coding you cannot
develop the game because you will not
know the nitty gritty
so the domain expertise on top
the computer or it expertise will always
be the best combination
or success is my my message
to the young people or the young
graduates of today
yeah so dr sencity i think this is such
an exciting topic i mean i'm
sure we could go on but i think in
interest of time and
you know respecting your time and
everybody else's i think
let me pause there any closing
statements you'd like to make i mean
something you'd like to leave the
audience with
there are so many things we are teachers
we are preachers
and at times we don't miss that
opportunity
i would basically say that
you should be more adoptable we have
been discussing that you yourself said
that
and there are examples which we have
quoted
do whatever you do with your heart in it
be very competitive
after that pass and fail will not mean
much in my opinion you will be able to
take everything in your stride
even if success comes it will not go to
your head and even if failure is there
you will not ruin your life that is what
i would say
the other thing i already said whatever
knowledge you do unless you share it
you'll not get the recognition
and recognition in my opinion the wealth
of life
is not money wealth of life is
recognition and therefore whatever good
you are able to do
share it it will always keep you in good
speed and you will feel very satisfied
with your life that's something very
very important
and at times when it comes to indian
setup
in terms of work i've seen many people
and they are at work
they are worried about home and when
they are at home they are worried about
the work
i think that cocktail is not a very good
cocktail in terms of
process or whatever which is there and
that's another thing i'll also possibly
say that
while you work in a certain domain keep
something outside the domain as your
work or interest because sometimes life
may not be in the same linear fashion
functioning at that time you will
survive with those things those
interests may be sports hobbies
debates celebrations whatever it may be
even politicking teaching profession is
the one which i love
one i said is because of the longevity
of life the second is
i can be a teacher but i can also be an
entrepreneur
i can start my companies such features
are not easily available in other
professions when you are working for a
company
you become yourself an entrepreneur is
not possible
and see the top i can become a
politician also very easily i can
contest for anything
i can be a minister and a lot of
educationists have become ministers
all that so what i'm trying to say is
keep the interest
uh go into a profession where you can
serve your interest all that will also
be
very nice now in in the current context
the other important thing is when the
freedom is given autonomy is given
be very very cautious don't be
indiscriminate
when we have a lot of money and freedom
with the money and we become
indiscriminate
that is the fall of us and that's where
we need to be taking care
another thing which is becoming
important in indian context is the
quality
we were never much quality conscious was
the attitude
we used to have a long long time but now
we know that the quality
pays dividends in long long run long
term
and ultimately if you have to succeed be
aware of yourself we have been doing
swaps of
institutions and organizations and
products and processes
but we are not generally very happy with
stock of your own self
the moment you are told these are your
weaknesses people feel bad about it
i think that should go away and if you
do that
i think you will succeed so this would
be
my broad message and one message i
already given be a team player
all the time you cannot do everything in
life today i'm pretty sure
uh uh kashabi that when you found it
simply learned there must have been
many many co-founders you are also a
co-founder that's because the team is
required
people with different attributes can
excel as someone in marketing someone in
finance someone in technology someone in
something else processes and protection
and therefore make sure that you have
the teams
to work with and therefore you can
always
uh swing through the difficult times
easily if you have the team
these are some of the tips some of the
messages or some of the
things i can possibly share i know these
are difficult
to follow some of them they can be done
only with the
life's experience but then try to
accelerate that if you want to be
more successful that's what i would say
thank you so much doctor i think uh
i found the discussion to be very
valuable and thought-provoking
i'm sure that the audience has also
really enjoyed it
i'd like to thank you for taking your
time out and joining us for this webinar
um i'd also like to thank the all the
viewers and audience who's logged in for
this webinar
um and stuart for setting it up
for us so thank you everyone and
stewart over to you i think we've
covered what we had
let me also thank everyone especially
the audience
who have joined at this hour and this
point of time and raise questions
also thanks to you kashabji and everyone
in simply learn and your team
for inviting me it's a great deal of
learning experience for me as well
thank you so much namaskar thank you
thank you sir
okay and thank you dr sanchez thank you
kesha
and thanks to our audience
we invite you to join our next webinar
which will be
two weeks from now tuesday august 25th
uh on the topic of digital marketing
current issues
for websites and how to pivot your
business
to adapt to the new normal with matt
bailey
uh founder of sitelogic and a faculty
member at simplylearn
and you can connect with us follow us
with our various social media handles on
facebook twitter and linkedin
we look forward to seeing you at future
webinars
and that concludes today's presentation
so at this time i'd like to invite
our panelists and our attendees to log
off
webex there will be a survey that pops
up for the attendees
and if you would take a few minutes to
answer those questions
we would appreciate that um again thank
you all very much and this concludes
the webinar thank you
[Music]
you